today on stick to football we break down
everything that you missed in week three
of the NFL season and look at week four
of the college football season because
we were on the road I don't know about
you Connor I spent basically Sunday
night and all day Monday getting caught
up on the games that we missed because
my focus was on Wisconsin Michigan and
then really went straight to the Texas
game that evening Texas Oklahoma State
so like Georgia Notre Dame I didn't
watch a snap in that game until we got
home from Wisconsin which once again was
absolutely amazing yeah we did the
absolute reverse here because while I
was standing next to you and you were
watching Texas I was watching Notre Dame
in Georgia so I had to do the catching
up on the other end but a lot of good
games this week I think this Matt so far
was the best prospect week a lot of
different guys stood out really on the
national stage in really big matchups
we're gonna talk about all of them today
on the draft radar in our third segment
just to go over well actually in the
second segment just to go over who stood
out $100 handshakes Sleeper
disappointments so a really really fun
week of college football I think the
best one so far yeah I agree the best
one that we've seen so far and just a
reminder before we jump into the show
the next tailgate tour stop will be
October 6th
in Kansas City it's a Sunday night
football game Colts at Chiefs Melo and I
will be taking over a lot Jake which is
like if you know Arrowhead and
tailgating this is probably like the
rowdiest part of the stadium so lot Jay
will be there with the the tailgate
Cruiser that we had last year at Ohio
State Michigan the massive 27 foot yeah
it's gonna be great three TVs couches
operation BBQ will be there catering the
event and they'll be raising money for
all the like disaster relief programs
that they do so it's gonna be a good
time again you don't have to sign up for
a ticket you don't even really need a
ticket to the game just come out to lot
J if you want to tailgate with us I will
be there Melo will be there Connor one
guy who might also be in Kansas City by
then is Jalen Ramsey who trade last week
and his agent David Mulligan I said hey
we want to trade and the Jags it really
seemed by Sunday they were like no we
don't want to trade you you're really
good at football and so Sunday night
Jalen gets the flu the flu people
watching on YouTube can see the Eric
jaelyn gets the flu and now it sounds
like he might not practice with the flu
until he gets traded which I would
assume he would then magically be cured
I think Matt there's a lot of different
various versions of the flu some really
bad some not I can't speak for Jaylyn
maybe he is sick this might be something
that if he was happy it wouldn't even
got out there I might have to spend a
day off of practice or you know just
resting up so I don't really know what
to say about the flu symptoms but I
think it's pretty obvious Jalen Ramsey
still is not happy I know the team has
tried to repair the relationship between
him and Tom Coughlin's there's clearly
problems here I don't blame him now like
you said if your Jacksonville you're
looking at it and going we have a
franchise player on the defensive end we
have a young quarterback that is
bringing an energy to this team right
now while Nick Foles is out and might be
able to keep us afloat while Nick Foles
is out we're starting to believe again
Andrew Luck retired the Texans and
obviously even Jacoby Brissette now for
the Colts looked good but this division
is up for grabs and Jacksonville doesn't
want to trade away probably their best
player so when it comes down to it they
got to figure it out and guess what
cures the flu Matt not medicine
a lot of money and I think at some point
they got to back up the Brinks truck and
make this man happy I don't know if it's
fixable right now but that's the only
cure I don't know if it is either and
yet money does solve a lot of problems
but it it can't fix like a broken
relationship and if Tom Coughlin is the
problem here like everyone's saying he's
the problem
I don't see y'all touchdown Tommy being
the kind of guy that's like hey Jalen
here's 70 million dollars I'm sorry for
being a grumpy old man hey that's just
not gonna work so I I still think that
we could see this happen throughout the
week where he does get traded we're
sitting here Tuesday morning he hasn't
been yet but I would not be shocked if
he is moved by the end of this week just
because it seems to me like he's not
holding out because he wants a new
contract he's holding out because he's
not happy with Jacksonville so trilliums
exactly so I think that's where they're
kind of at a crossroads a little bit
moving on here do
I want to talk a lot about the year one
in year two quarterbacks but first I
want to talk about Cam Newton because
obviously he didn't play Sunday and the
Panthers won with Kyle Allen at
quarterback and it comes out now that
Cam Newton it sounds like has a list
ranked injury and I'm not the biggest
Cam Newton fan I think he is and we've
seen him regress at the quarterback
position mostly due to injury but I do
think that this is another situation
where this team has to be very very
careful of how they handle this his
contract is up basically after next
season he has started to break down
physically I would not be in any hurry
to get him back on the field right now
especially with the way Kyle Allen
played I'll be it against the Arizona
Cardinals but I think you kind of use
this as an opportunity to evaluate the
future and see what you might have at
the quarterback position I think so too
I don't think you need to rush cam back
now say this about cam this is starting
to feel like Andrew Luck all over again
you're talking about an MVP player at
the quarterback position that has led
you to a Super Bowl an MVP Matt that
does not look like the same guy anymore
and that is not mental with Cam Newton I
don't even think it's the pieces around
him because there are pieces around him
finally I think it's physical and I
think it's a shame I think if you're if
you have a young quarterback right now
you're learning a lot of lessons by
watching Andrew Luck retire Cam Newton's
30 years old and he's completely beaten
up and doesn't look like the same guy
anymore Aaron Rodgers has been you know
even up and down he's been beaten up in
the past he's not on the level of luck
or Cam and he's much older but just
saying you need to take care of your
quarterback you can't rush them back I
think the bills they went out and got a
lot of offensive linemen because they
were worried about this with Josh Allen
I think the Ravens have built a system
that hopefully protects Lamar Jackson
the Jets couldn't protect Sam Donald
from mono but it's not a physical
beating they they Joe Douglas got this
job because they know they need a guy
that can come in and build an offensive
line next offseason the Dolphins don't
give a [ __ ] about Josh Rosen so that
doesn't count but the point stands
across the board the Browns need to
figure it out with Baker Mayfield Cam
Newton is just now the another Andrew
Luck and it's a shame I hope it doesn't
end that
it's good that Kyle Allen looked really
really good what a story Kyle Allen is
just the comeback story that he was
former top five star recruit
basically failed quarterback almost it
wasn't even drafted and now looks like a
you know really promising player in the
NFL but for cam man I just you got to
give him a lot of time a lot of time
yeah if you rush him back he might just
be one more hit away from being like I
can't do this anymore
not at the level I used to play at it's
kind of a Kyle Allen we're not gonna
talk about because he is not a first or
he wasn't drafted so I guess he doesn't
fall into the criteria of those
quarterbacks that we were gonna talk
about but it's interesting to me that he
once again beats out Kyle Emery because
is the dude that when they were at am ie
he he kind of took Kyler's job and now
we see him go into the desert and beat
up that Cardinals team which this this
does segues perfectly into talking about
the first and second-year quarterback
switch Colin is the second-year
quarterback I don't know on nfl.com he
doesn't come up on the stats that's the
second-year quarterback I don't know
what I'm missing here yeah so he went
undrafted in 2018 but he actually he
bounced around on the practice squad and
I think he even got cut from so that's
how bad it's been at times for Kyle
Allen it's that crazy so but NFL doc
companies get their [ __ ] together
because he's definitely a second-year
quarterback yeah it's it's a word
situation and actually Matt I believe
Cuyler took his job so this rivalry this
rivalry goes on for a long time now back
and forth
either way Kyle Allen you're the man
great star great you know really debut
after such a long road hopefully it
continues let's talk about the year 1
and year 2 quarterbacks you know we're
gonna start with Daniel Jones this is
exciting
this is also a perfect example of now
the media running with something and
just going buck wild with it yeah let's
examine this game in a nutshell
Daniel Jones played great he played
great yes he fumbled twice there was a
drop to pick but he scored four
touchdowns he ran for two he threw for
two he did it in clutch situations he
was doing it under pressure he looked
really good some credits of Pat Shermer
who does not get a lot this
they built for him was perfect it was
absolutely perfect
now this Bucks team mature Biscay threw
for six touchdowns and 350 yards against
last year I know now Todd Bowles is
taken over but I'm not taking away from
Daniel Jones I just want to put it in
perspective this one game is a
phenomenal start and I will gladly eat
the L if he turns into a great player
now it's one game now he gets a
Washington team that looks lifeless for
most of Monday Night Football got to
keep it going got a win without say Quon
well I think context matters yeah
everyone who listens to me regularly
knows that that's my that's like my one
you know Testament is you have to put
context when it comes to scouting an
evaluation the key for me I thought
Jones looked really good in the fourth
quarter I definitely thought he did some
throw when it's a guy's first start and
they got they got behind and I saw guys
on Twitter like told you Eli wasn't the
problem it's the defense and then this
comeback was really epic and I think
that the key is he was so poised and it
never looked like the game was too big
or too fast for Daniel Jones which you
know going back to the things I liked it
Duke was his ability to improvise you
know there was the game against North
Carolina where he he really had to run
the ball a lot at Duke and was very
successful
there were times where you could see him
get to second third reads in his
progression because he's able to move
around in the pocket so that translates
well I mean you're right the scheme was
really good I'm excited and I've said
this before I know Melo has said it as
well like this was a guy that we all
kind of were down on in the draft
process as a 10 pick write as a top ten
pick when he got drafted so highly it
was like oh this is too high for him but
the reaction to that now makes me want
him to succeed so I'm excited and and
like I said the schedules not not super
tough for them so he's probably gonna
have some momentum going under him say
Quan being out is definitely gonna hurt
but I'm excited for Daniel Jones I'm not
gonna like I'm not gonna downplay the
performance Giants fans deserve to be
happy today but let's let's see where it
continues to go gardner minshew came
back to earth a little bit this week now
at least statistically they continue to
roll though they beat Tennessee 20 to 7
Gardner is just I mean he's a phenomena
right now it despite like the jords and
the mustache and the jockstrap story
he's like he's actually playing
really good football and it's funny
because who he reminded me of coming out
of college was like a cocky Andy Dalton
and I feel like that's kind of who we're
seeing him play as like he doesn't turn
the ball over he might not have 400 yard
games but he's just super efficient but
his leadership the way that the team has
bought in around him is really that I
think the best part of this story is you
got a guy who was pick 199 just like Tom
Brady and now looks like you know
through three games he looks like he
could be the dude that puts Nick Foles
on the bench I think energy really
matters as a backup quarterback the
energy you come in and bring in there it
makes a huge difference and I think the
team actually believes they can win with
Gardner Minshew and speaking of that
energy they did lose but I think Lamar
Jackson has brought the same energy for
Baltimore where they believe that
defense is very good that's a very well
coached team the other Harbaugh not the
one at Michigan but obviously John
Harbaugh is one of the most underrated
coaches in the NFL absolutely Lamar
Jackson maybe a little bit of a comeback
down-to-earth moment against a very
tough Kansas City Chiefs team but at the
end of the day he's not the reason the
Ravens are gonna lose games and I think
that's very exciting for Baltimore we're
seeing a lot of these young quarterbacks
that are not holding their teams back
it's really either their defenses
sometimes the offensive line or the
skilled players so Gardiner Lamar
they're elevating their teams and now on
four and Daniel Jones now mad I think we
have to talk about some of the
not-so-great performances with your one
in your two quarterbacks and I would add
Josh Allen in there with the energy yes
of course they're three you know which I
don't think anyone expected I know the
offense hasn't always looked great but
they're three you know and I think josh
is playing very well I mean he's always
gonna be a guy that turns the ball over
a little bit you know three
interceptions yeah but what he does a
runner
what he does have big moments that that
absolutely helps them now the guys who
aren't playing well this is not me
taking shots at Oklahoma quarterbacks I
want to be fair because last year when
Baker went off I was all about it I
praised him he looked great Baker is
holding the ball way too long this year
he's leaving clean pockets he's missing
Oh
receivers I don't know if it is the fact
that this team is you know there was
really built together over the offseason
if they're still gelling if it's the new
offensive system with Freddie kitchens
if Freddie has too much on his plate
something is wrong in Cleveland and when
I watch them play I see Baker like I was
yelling at the TV yesterday because he's
just running out of clean pockets and I
don't I don't know if it's guys running
the wrong routes it's it's too hard to
tell but without knowing the play call
what's going on but Baker has not looked
good this year if he even that game that
we were at when they beat the Jets he
didn't really look good there was the
Odell plays really saved them Baker
hasn't looked good and Kyler Murray is
just not getting it done I mean four
touchdowns three picks doesn't even
begin to tell the story I mean it's just
so dink and dunk in that offense they're
only averaging 6.1 yards per attempt
that's just not good enough that's not
gonna get it done in the NFL yeah what
Kyler Murray was drafted we expected it
to be four explosive plays and we just
haven't seen much of that some of that
is on the offense with Kliff Kingsbury
I'll tell you this Matt I have been
beyond underwhelmed by Freddie kitchens
and Kliff Kingsbury Freddie to a larger
extent and we'll see I mean yeah I could
sit here and kill Adam GaSe right now we
can wait to do that when Sam darn 'old
is back I'm not gonna really get into
it's not about lutely aw come when Luke
Falk is the starter let's see how that
plays out but he can enter this group of
coaches that what's going on Baker is
drifting which tells you he does not
trust the offensive line Baker Mayfield
you're not running away from Aaron
Donald or Dante Fowler stop trying to
run away from I don't care if you trust
your offensive line or not watch Daniel
Jones
use climbing the pocket or running up
the middle as an example staying in
there I'm not I'm not out on Baker
that's not it I love Baker Mayfield I
think he's a great player this is a team
that has some serious flaws right now
and it starts with the lack of trust in
the past protection they're running
concepts that are taking away too long
to develop we'll get into all the Freddy
stuff but it's clearly affecting Baker
Mayfield right now yeah it absolutely is
and here's the thing if you're a fan of
these teams and your quarterbacks
struggling it's early it's we've played
three games there is still
you know basically 75% of a season left
there's plenty of time to turn things
around maybe we see Todd mock and get
more involved there maybe cliff gets a
little more comfortable in Arizona but
of the year two quarterbacks it's it's
unfortunate but those are the your one
in year two those are the struggle buses
right now the most unfortunate is that
Josh Rosen does not stand a chance I
mean there was one drive where he went
down the field all passes and they just
I think they ran three straight run
plays in a row in the red zone and that
was it and Josh was having his own
problems but you watch the games and you
go this Miami team I won't do it but I'm
gonna do it you know what Alabama beat
the Dolphins just it's just they're bad
they're really really bad I know they
want to be bad I get it they want to be
bad but you can't even evaluate players
right now in this offense it's it's
almost time to really just talk about
TOA and the dolphins and whoever else
they draft so there'll be our first
fixing segment if that gets here I'll
DUP as a Dolphins fan that one will be
here soon all right let's take a break
we come back we're gonna look at week
three of the college football season
from an NFL draft perspective it's time
to take a look back at week three of the
college football season from a draft
perspective also to hand out our $100
handshakes and Connor my first standout
start my own standout star excuse me I
got a look at Michael Pittman jr. what
this guy did Friday night against a very
good Utah defense by the way was just
phenomenal he has been good all year
long as USC has now played three
quarterbacks the one constant is that
Michael Pittman jr. continues to make
big plays ten catches 232 yards on one
TD with Mason Fink in there at
quarterback he looked amazing six-foot
for 220 pounds my junior evaluation of
him I was always really concerned about
speed does he have the deep speed to
pull away from people I think we saw in
this Utah game he does that's seventy
nine yard a 78-yard touchdown he has the
speed to get down the field and make big
plays I am really excited about Michael
Pittman jr. and I can't wait to see him
at the Senior Bowl because I think he
with his size where this route running
could pose some really interesting
one-on-one matchups he's a fun player
it's awesome there
giving him vertical targets this year
Matt he's really climbing the ladder
going up winning the football running
away from to vent defenders and just
sticky hands honestly a really really
exciting senior year for Michael Pittman
jr. already I'm going where we were and
that was Madison Wisconsin watching him
at the game Jonathan Taylor that is
maybe mr. Heisman Jonathan Taylor Matt
he left the game with cramps he missed
basically half the game and he still
rumbled for over 200 yards on 23 carries
he averaged almost nine yards a carry
against Michigan Michigan was picked to
win the big ten I got to give a
shout-out to the Big Uglies on Wisconsin
for giving him a lot of room but the
burst to get to the outside for Jonathan
Taylor the straight line speed at 220
plus pounds we heard Adam Kramer saying
it on our show that released Monday he's
gonna run sub for four they think he's
gonna run in the four 3s he's a track
kind of guy Jonathan Taylor you are the
standout star of this week in college
football he is making the running back
conversation as far as the draft a fun
one because it's like he and DeAndre
swift just keep trading punches
basically it's the number one back I'm
gonna take it to that same game Conor
because the disappointment for me the
biggest disappointment of the week
number one that we had to leave Madison
Wisconsin number two shake Patterson
continues to struggle 14 of 32 and I
know he had 219 yards two people oh he
had two touchdowns yeah you can really
think Ronnie bell for that because Shea
Patterson looked completely rattled and
lost in a game that early on they need a
big place he could not provide them and
then I'm gonna say the Michigan defense
to what the hell guys this was a team
that with Don Brown as defensive
coordinator we were told there's not
gonna be a drop-off we're young you know
there's kaliki Hudson and Brad Hawkins
and all these Josh medalists these dudes
can play no they can't they are just not
good and it's simple things like it's
just run fits there is no tough now
there's no dog on this defense anymore
wina vich was that guy
Devin Bush was that guy and it is gone
right now Michigan used to think about
Michigan it's like they run the football
they stop the run they can't do either
one right now it is incredibly
disappointing to look at a blueblood
program the
continually be ranked in the top 10 with
what they have in terms of tradition
coaching the pedigree the recruiting
ability they're terrible right now I
think they're the most overrated team in
the country headed into the weekend and
they really just got put on display by
Wisconsin yeah they just came out and
looked like they really didn't want to
be on the field it was so bad
Matt bet it sucked the life for a bit
until jump around out of the Wisconsin
crowd that's how bad they were it wasn't
it was 14 nothing game was over no one
cared Michigan didn't want to be on the
field the coaches what did they do for
two weeks I don't know what they did it
was just unbelievable to witness that
score doesn't even tell half the story
of the game now I'm gonna go back to
your game your standout star was Michael
Pitt Michael Pittman jr. what happened
in the Utah secondary I mean they have
all-conference players draftable players
in this secondary they have good players
in the front seven they're an
experienced team with a lot of mostly
all returning starters on this defense
they got lit up lit up I just couldn't
believe it I was so excited for this
Utah defense this year yes it's one game
we know the path the pac-12 just eats at
each other like crazy nobody's gonna let
anyone make the playoff but this Utah
secondary got shredded against USC they
absolutely did watching that game Friday
night with the six Football Hall of Fame
I was I was blown away let's look at a
sleeper in terms of draft again not in
terms of college football but a draft
sleeper that's not getting enough love
mine I'm gonna go a little bit Homer
here but I got Devon Devon a wide
receiver for Texas in their two biggest
games this year he has shown up enormous
Lee against LSU and against Oklahoma
State he has 24 catches for 264 yards
and three touchdowns with Colin Johnson
out this past week a lot of people were
very critical how could Texas score
without Colin Johnson would the
backfield beat up well Devon Duvernay
was the answer those 12 catches were
enormous they got on the board early
Texas did Sam Ehlinger had another game
very very efficient but Devon Duvernay
he has legitimate speed this is a 10/2
and 100-meter guy you saw that against
LSU we saw it again against Oklahoma
State in a very good wide receiver class
there's a lot of them I don't think
Duvernay is a first or second maybe not
even a third round guy but he's
I'm gonna really like in this process
because you can find ways to get him the
ball and he gave me an explosive
playmaker he's played on the outside for
Texas he's played in the slot he's
really been all over the field that's
the kind of stuff that you know when we
look at guys like scary Terry from last
year we all love Terry because he could
play anywhere he's gonna help on special
teams Devin du Vernay is this year's
Terry McLaren I like it that's a great
take I mean you see scary Terry catching
a touchdown every week race ray all the
guy does is make plays and he's not
getting much help I think those numbers
will go up even higher when Dewayne
Haskins gets in the game or even Trent
Williams comes back we'll see my sleeper
here I'm going to the big ten Michigan
State
Joe Bochy Matt it's hard to be a sleeper
and when you have a game where you had
14 tackles a sack and interception and
broke up two passes I don't hear anyone
talking about Joe Bochy and it's time we
do senior linebacker he's gonna get to
go to the Senior Bowl
he's a tackling machine great instincts
I think he looks pretty athletic he's
just a great player he's the leader in
the middle of a very very talented
defense I know the offense hasn't helped
them that much at Michigan State but a
very talented defense at six to 230 he's
your typical size for a middle
linebacker in today's NFL right now
these guys don't really play at 260 255
very often anymore in the middle they
need to go sideline to sideline Joe
Bochy have yourself a week have yourself
a season already 40 tackles on the
season yeah he has looked impressive
there's always that one big tin
linebacker realized no one can stop this
guy and I love Kenny willikers as
everyone knows that Michigan State
defense is for real all right let's hand
out some $100 handshakes man will rip
through these mine I have four to give
out to a once again absolutely amazing
five touchdowns as Alabama just
continues to be unstoppable which I'm
starting to think I could throw a
touchdown with those receivers there are
four receivers are the best in country I
know we talked about maybe Clemson maybe
Michigan USC's good no its Alabama those
four wideouts are just absolutely
incredible
Sammy Ehlinger got to give him one
because again a lot of people thought
Oklahoma State was gonna upset Texas
they did not because of Ellen's play I
know you throw high yeah I mean again
you were with us and I was like I would
not bet on this game I do not feel good
about it but
Ehlinger was really just I mean he was
the offensive weapon again for Texas
that's a big win for them Derrick brown
who I think is the best offensive tackle
in the country he dominated a Texas A&M
team that he's like this is a good team
we talked about Kellan Monde and their
ability to run the ball and they're
generally pretty physical he had four
tackles three of them for a loss two
sacks two passes defense he almost
picked one off and ran it back for a
touchdown and he forced a fumble I don't
know that you can have a better single
game than Derrick brown hat against
Texas A&M if you're looking for a game
to go back and watch if like Oh wide
starck Brown d-line one in this class
that's it and that's a marquee team
Texas A&M this isn't it wasn't against
Kent State it was against Texas A&M Andy
did it well hurt
so Derek Brown is getting $100 handshake
for me and then how about this one in a
game that I thought was over completely
over
Anthony Gordon throws nine touchdown
passes at quarterback for UCLA and one
of the greatest comebacks in college
football history I know everybody's like
otis chip have his swagger back i don't
know if he does but if you could throw
nine touchdowns in one game you have to
get some recognition from us oh you have
to that game was just unbelievable going
back and watching that i talked some of
my friends at our UCLA fans and they're
like yeah I felt sleep that's how it
goes when you're down that many points
but let's rip through my hundred-dollar
handshakes here starting with the very
obvious one let's give the big ugly's
Wisconsin's offensive line each of them
get $20 out of the hundred they blew
Michigan off the ball embarrass them go
back and watch Jonathon Taylor's longest
run of the game there were bodies on the
floor from that wisconsin front joe
burrow i mean every week it's just the
jobber a week scoring points at their
points this guy went from looking like a
game managing quarterback to the dude
out there in this new offense just
putting the ball everywhere another
quarterback that we always talk about
his physical limitations and how smart
of a guy he is I thought this was Jake
Fromm's best week just throwing the ball
go watch the incompletions he just
looked so confident he was throwing on
the move he was throwing with a little
more velocity than usual you sure topped
a couple targets but overall getting the
ball outside the hashes driving the ball
this was a really really nice step but
gets a Notre Dame team that was
the road and came to play they gave
Georgia everything they had but from and
that Georgia front that Georgia defense
DeAndre swift they were too much to
handle that's why they're one of the
best teams in college football my last
one from the same game because we really
don't talk about this guy enough but
chase Claypool has just been a machine
for Notre Dame all he does is makes
place in the red zone on the sideline
down the field on vertical plays I love
chase Claypool I love what I've seen
from him so far and he's somebody that
you talked about how crowded this wide
receiver classes Matt this wide receiver
group it's time to get claypoole's name
into the conversation a little bit more
Connor we're gonna go rapid-fire a
little bit through the NFL week three
season we're not gonna go through every
game because that would take four hours
but I do want to at least call out some
of the notable performances it's week
four which means we have some byes
coming up so there's a good part of the
season to kind of take a break look at
what's working what's not working the
best win that I saw on Sunday and I
actually changed my answer because I
originally had the Niners over the
Steelers because I thought Nick Bosa
played well we saw some of the young
guys step up but I changed my answer
because the Kansas City Chiefs beating
the Baltimore Ravens is is I mean these
are two undefeated teams Lamar Jackson
as you said earlier in the show had
looked really unstoppable up to this
point I think what's most encouraging
for me is that the Chiefs were able to
corral him enough they were able to slow
him down enough to win this game but
also that they can see the offense
without Eric Fisher and without Tyree
kill without Damian Williams was still
able to score not at will but at a high
enough rate to beat a team that I think
has a great chance to win the AFC North
they have a good chance to make a pretty
good playoff run here so beating a very
good Baltimore team and this game was
close it was 33 28 Baltimore made a nice
push late I think that is a huge win for
Kansas City in the home opener to really
not that that team needs more confidence
but that should be a confidence boosting
win for the Chiefs
yeah and they kind of played in
conditions that you think would favor
the Ravens a little bit I mean the
Chiefs if they play in dry weather you
know they could throw the ball around
the field all day and Pat mahomes still
did but once again this was definitely a
great game a great matchup these teams
might meet again so a really nice win
for Kansas City
I'm going with a quiet one here it
didn't really get a lot of love but the
Texans beating the Chargers it was the
deshaun Watson show again Matt I mean
deshaun Watson has found himself in the
MVP conversation the plays he makes with
his legs and throwing on the move
keeping his eyes down the field he's
phenomenal and this is a Chargers team
that was supposed to contend with that
Kansas City team in that division
the Texans need to put their foot on the
gas and win their division Andrew Luck
retired I know Jacobi's been good
Jacksonville is making a little run with
Gardner Minshew I don't know what this
Tennessee team is but right now the
Texans it's time to put the foot on the
gas this was one of those wins where
they did exactly that I want to throw an
honorable mention in here because we
really never give them enough love I
know we've even doubted them how about
the Lions going out and beaten the
Eagles there are things wrong with the
Eagles right now and they need to get
right I don't know if at Thursday Night
Football matchup against Green Bay is
that answer maybe they'll have to wait
till they play the Jets the following we
following week and we'll see if
Darnell's back but the Lions went out
and got the job done that's a really big
win they deserve some credit they're
undefeated because of the tie the Lions
are they look like a completely
different team they looked in week one
so that's a very very good on how about
the best individual performance I got to
go with our guide danger danger zone my
goodness Daniel Jones come back win was
phenomena Danny dimes that's the worst
name danger zones danger zone is way
better right exactly get him a top gun
get him a bomber let's see it I really
do I think deploys that we saw from him
late in the game the ability to win with
his legs like I said the two rushing
touchdowns I'm so here for it so I think
Daniel Jones is gonna get my best
performance of the week because we did
this probably before Monday Night
Football which I'm gonna get to a little
bit later because there were some beat
downs on that one our guy Taylor Gabriel
went off but Daniel Jones gets it for me
here now if a kicker could just hit an
extra point chip shot I'm taking the one
we'd be talking about that's a Mike
Evans against the Giants secondary I
mean holy [ __ ] Matt did he go off three
touchdowns 10 catches he had almost 200
receiving yards
basically if Jameis Winston threw the
ball in his direction he was catching it
for a big play this game should have
been over thanks to Mike Evans but in a
shocking fashion another NFL kicker
missed a kick that
affected the entire game so Daniel Jones
that's a great pick from you and that
has to be the one this week for best
performance don't sleep on Mike Evans
he's on pace for Hall of Fame wide
receiver numbers I love what he's done
can't wait to see what he can do when
they move on I know Jameis has not been
a big problem this year but I don't know
if he's the answer for the future
honorable mention quick one Kyle Allen
we talked about in the beginning the
show have yourself a week Kyle Allen
yeah he absolutely did and and good to
get that first big win how about the
worst moment there were I think a lot of
them there were some bad coaching
decisions there were some bad missed
kicks I got to go with the sake on
injury though just a heikal sprain to
the best running back in football in a
player carrying the hopes and dreams of
many fantasy football players listen to
this show say Kahn's
injury yeah Melo has them as well say
quads injury was a huge just oh my god
please be okay moment and I know they
say it'll be a couple weeks he's hopping
around on the the crutches celebrating
after the win which don't do that
anymore
just sit your ass down sick ones injury
was that probably the like stomach
tightening moment of week three for me
yeah it sucks it absolutely sucks four
to eight weeks a high ankle sprain they
linger you can't rush back from them
because you could just read it's the
easiest thing to reactivate it really is
so they got a it sucks because Daniel
Jones comes out and plays well and
that's his a guy it took away you saw
daniel Jones hole in the ball a little
longer when you did enough say Quan is
an outlet anymore so that injury
absolutely sucks I'm gonna go with
Freddie kitchens red zone plays that
really decided the potential outcome of
the game Nick Chubb was your best player
in that game you don't look at Nick
Chubb you just keep running these plays
with Baker Mayfield that are taking long
to develop no one's open there's
pressure every play I forget the fourth
and nine draw whatever the [ __ ] that was
I've just abysmal play calling from
Freddie kitchens that was the worst
moment of the week yeah I don't
I loved the like Oh Freddie's different
and he's raw and you know he's not he
doesn't know he's doing I don't know if
it does I really don't and it's just ah
yeah it's not a good look for him right
now I really do think like let's give
Todd Monken
a little bit more control let him help
out a little bit because my god do they
need it how odd the
just beat down I don't know if you've
stayed up late enough to watch this one
did
Kaleo Mac May has made the Gruden boys
his [ __ ]
he really has he is owned Jay and Jon
Gruden the last two times that they have
played he went absolutely off he was
unstoppable even if it wasn't like just
pure sax I mean he forced two fumbles
last night as well he was all over the
field three tackles 2 sacks two forced
fumbles Khalil Mack gets pissed off when
he has to play the Gruden's I absolutely
love it it's so funny and then one time
they tried to like kind of block him
with two tight ends he was moving sofa
it looked like a tractor-trailer coming
down the highway it's probably the
scariest thing you could ever see I went
with the Patriots defense versus the
Jets offense I know it's Luke Falk
I mean lifeless yes it was 3214 the game
was worse the Jets scored on a special
teams touchdown and Jamal Adams had a
pick six the offense could not literally
move forward the entire day that
Patriots defense I know once again it's
Luke Falk but they're such a well
coached unit and they're just not
letting any opposition score right now
it's as simple as that so that was my
beatdown of the week sad to say it is
draft on draft time we have some great
ones this week and some new ones I like
that we're getting some new listeners in
here at the dill dozer 72 great [ __ ]
name buddy that's amazing with Chase
young being so dominant could we get a
top-five edge rushing prospects you've
seen over the last prime year five years
from each of you and just chase young
making any of your list so I put this in
here and actually all I'm gonna plug my
own work here Tuesday morning I had an
article come out that was my top ten
prospects of the last decade 2010 to
2019 so you can kind of see where I've
ranked the top ten guys I'm not trying
to hedge because I do think chase young
will end up in my top five barring
injury I really really like him but I
think it's too early and we've seen
three games visions and yes he's been
amazing seven sacks he looks unstoppable
I won't put a grade on a player this
early in the year because too much can
happen and Ohio State really hasn't
played new one yet not that that changes
traits but I just want to wait to put a
grade on a player the highest ranked
defense
means I've seen von Miller is my top
miles Garrett was second highest I
believe Bradley chub Nick and Joey Bosa
were all about the same so that's my top
five as of now I could see chase Young
being number three on that list behind
von Miller and behind Miles Garrett when
it's all said and done for me and I so
clowny I know everyone's gonna ask about
clowny
I liked clowny but the injury history
that was really a concern for me so I we
did things differently in 2014 a bleach
report we didn't do number grades on
players so unfortunately I can't cross
compare which is really annoying but I I
didn't I love clowny obviously but the
what he had hernia and then like there
was just some effort issues so he was
number two on my board that year but not
a top-five edge for me yeah in the last
five years so that would be that cuts
off at clown easier so Clara is not
eligible for this it starts at 2015 I
think for me and we won't it's hard to
get into this year chase Young has the
chance to be in that elite category he
really does miles Gera is the most rare
that I've seen in the last five years
and then Nick Bosa who was my number one
overall player last year some miles
Garrett Nick Bosa and then the
conversation gets interesting where it's
probably Joey Bosa Bradley Chubb and
then Brian burns actually was a top 10
player for me last year he was the
second edge after Nick Bosa so it's a
really interesting question I think the
point is when you stack it like those
five guys chase young would be in the
top five he lay that special are do you
go last five years for me then he
absolutely is it would be Miles Garrett
would be top and then it would actually
be funny enough he'd be Miles Garrett
Bradley Chubb Nick Bosa Josh Allen and
then Joey Bosa doing well
Ohio State not bad at developing
football players second question at
Young Money Ryan if he never plays
another down in the NFL is Antonio Brown
a Hall of Famer I've notice in here
because I think we just need to tell you
the answer is emphatically no he's not
top 20 in any statistical category he is
also just a turd head off the field no
one's gonna want to deal with that I
mean look
guys like tio who really got penalized
because of his off-field stuff no way in
hell does Antonio Brown ever make the
Hall of Fame yeah he won't he actually
was two to three good years away from
probably being in and you know 31 years
old that was very realistic Matt I mean
extremely realistic so he blew it it's
as simple as that
now you make a great point he's not top
20 in anything even worse when you're
he's thirty fourth in receiving yards
and that's kind of where he hovers for
most of his categories he played in the
greatest passing era in football history
so the numbers are even more inflated
because somebody wrote back to me and it
was a great point they're like his
career is very comparable to Tori hole
and that Rams offense Torry Holt had you
know some of the greatest years for a
wide receiver but Antonio Brown played
in an era where I mean let's be real the
numbers should be even higher he doesn't
have more receiving yards than somebody
like Brandon Marshall to put this in
perspective okay I want to make that
clear Brandon Marshall so was he one of
the most dominant players of the last
couple of years at his position yeah he
checks that box but he won't this is
what the Hall of Fame cares about not
saying this is what we care about
longevity doesn't have it do voters like
him know they hate him media doesn't
like Antonio Brown that matters we don't
have a vote so it doesn't matter but
people do not like him and probably will
not vote for him but even if he was
great great historic legendary they
would vote for him because you have to
he wasn't he didn't play long enough to
do that and my thing is if he had been
hurt and this was the end of his career
maybe because you could say man for like
four years there he was best receiver in
football okay but because of the way
that his career ended I think that's
what makes it's where you're no because
you're not getting not getting the
benefit of the doubt this question
apparently we I like to put repeats in
at poncey caliph who is was best as a
prospect Miles Garrett chase younger
Jamie Clanny we kind of touched on this
I still think it's Miles Garrett Miles
Garrett was so special I don't know if
smash that gets talked about enough
because the 2017 draft was really good
there's been a lot of hindsight of
should they have drafted patch of the
drafted deshaun Watson maybe but I still
think miles Garrett was and is
incredibly special I think he's the
third best pass rusher in football edge
rusher in football behind Khalil Mack
and Von Miller however you want to put
those two I think it's Miles Garant next
so he has exceptionally lived up to all
the promise that we saw at Texas A&M and
he's only getting better you know he's
only getting stronger I think we're
starting to see more if you know bulrush
moves from him where it's not just speed
I think the sky is the limit Miles
Garrett could be a hall-of-famer when
it's all said and done yeah it looks
like he's gonna pass von Miller this
year so cool Mack is next and he's so
young he's just a great football player
great attitude for that team and let's
not forget Matt his last year at college
he's playing hurt he was playing through
injury so goes to show you just how good
he was but chase song has a chance to be
the guy right under him and that's a
special player it would be really rare
to see so if chase Young stays on this
pace he's trying to climb into that
territory the next question from Coach
de ranch
what kind of statistical season would
chase you everyone loves chase young
would have to have to be considered to
be invited as a Heisman finalist so I
think it will help him because he plays
for such a premier school I I know
people remember I thought last year Josh
Allen should have been invited as a
Heisman finalist and it didn't happen
because people hate defense but his
stats were gonna if you had 18 and a
half tackles for a loss I believe he had
12 and a half sacks it didn't get
invited now Kentucky wasn't very good
excuse me 17 sacks 21 and a half tackles
for a loss with the ball game numbers in
there he didn't get invited I thought he
should have because those are ridiculous
numbers if chase Young gets in that
stratosphere he's gonna get invited
because Ohio State will most likely be
undefeated at that time and it is a
blueblood program and you know this year
like who else you gonna I mean Justin
feels jaylen hurts and to a Jonathan
Taylor if they go back to inviting five
guys I can see Jim at the invite Joe
burrow right now we'll see how burrow
makes it through the SEC schedule but
yeah I think I think he would have to
have 15 plus sacks I think he needs to
get 20 and it's not crazy he has seven
sacks right now they have one two three
four five six seven eight games left so
if he averaged he's averaging over I
think two sacks a game
if he just has one that would get him to
15 so he can get if you get 18 and Ohio
State goes undefeated which I think they
will here's the crazy part Matt does
justin fields cancel out his invite oh
sure no as we have seen this we have you
know with would be your Baker one the
reason I thought he wouldn't win was
because I really thought Marquis Brown
would cancel out so many of his votes
and we haven't seen a bit like is with
Judy and to opal they can't cancel each
other out excuse me I do think that
voters get a little fatigued with
certain schools like I work we don't
want to Ohio State guys you know they
want representation almost so it could
happen that way I hate it I was writing
about this do that actually yesterday in
Dhamma kansui is probably the one player
that had a chance to win the heisman of
defense since Charles Woodson because he
actually swept every award but the
Heisman that a defender can win he took
the Nagurski the Lombardi the Bednarik
everything like he swept them all the
Outland and was the AP Player of the
Year but didn't win the Heisman so I
think in JAMA kansui is like the
template maybe of this is how good you
have to be and still not win but get
that invite yes any caught a touchdown
which gets you publicity which matters
for the Heisman this is what I said when
Houston was trying to campaign it Oliver
last year you got to get him involved on
offense
I think they should play chase Young at
tight end against Rutgers oh yeah throw
it to him twice it makes a difference it
really does people go back to those
plays so chase young yeah I think it
sucks but he probably needs 20 sacks to
get the invite he does alright last
question from our guy bar up it was so
great meeting Bart and the rest of he's
thinking in Madison fortune-teller- time
which three you know NFL team loses
first which one has the longest winning
streak in which Owen three team wins
first a lot lot going on here
so which three-and-oh team loses first
it could be the Packers Thursday night
maybe but the Eagles are they don't even
have their clearly the the Eagles are
reeling but I think that's what makes
this game interesting is that I think
Jim's hobby I'm gonna pick this one I
think the Eagles can beat the Packers I
think Jim Schwartz will have
the defense back on track and they've
been closed they really it's like
they've been getting blown out every
week so I think the Packers are the
three you know team that loses first
I'll tell you who's on the radar only
because they are facing the most desk
one of not the most but a very desperate
football team right now the Browns are
coming to San Francisco on Monday night
and man this Baker Mayfield know he
needs a big win you know I would not
pick the Browns I think the Niners will
win that game and remain undefeated but
if you're looking on the radar you're
going man the Browns are desperate right
now man they need a road win against the
Niners not betting on it though Kyle
Shanahan coach circles around Freddie
kitchens oh god yeah so oh and three
team what are you thinking here this
one's tough because there's no one I
think they're feelers I do things I got
there Owen Owen 3 I know a lot of people
got on me because I was actually I
thought Mason Rudolph made some good
throws on Sunday and I know these guys
his stats didn't look great and yeah he
missed some throws too but that is a
very good Niners defense I don't know
why they've kind of been overlooked but
I mean they're playing amazing Armstead
has been unstoppable d-tackle Buckner's
great bose is good Fords good also we're
idiots
the Bengals or the Steelers have to be
one of the teams they played each other
if you want to know who's gonna be the
first oh and three teams it's gonna be
the Bengals of the Steelers right there
so a really good rounded draft on draft
question so once again thanks to Jordans
picked an our sponsor mercs cheese we
had a blast in Madison at the tailgate
tour has been phenomenal so if you could
make it out to any of the games I can't
recommend it enough it's really been a
good time it's been great to see
everyone and the football has been good
the football has been good we've been
really really fortunate with good games
so far it is only gonna get better I'm
very excited we have Colts Chiefs then
we have Texas oh you you and I are off
to London then we come back and hit LSU
at alabama and calloc Stanford and maybe
more this because of you guys this
continues to grow we might be adding
more games so stay tuned because there
might be more stick to football stops
along the way
Connor and I will be back Friday morning
with Melo as we break down the upcoming
week I feel like I'm starting to get
some heat back on my pics so I'm looking
forward to it's gotta be the mustache so
I'm looking forward to Friday because
I'm taking I'm over taking mellow this
week on the pics I feel good about it